[Music]
beautiful place catechol Caracol
kyrgyzstan 4th biggest city in the
country
i got so many friends here
[Music]
first impressions it's just as raw in
wild place roughly 65,000 people so has
the Tian Shan Mountains these massive
mountains coming out of the city on the
other side is lake is he call which is a
beautiful alpine lake with with deep
blue waters and massive mountains
falling into it don't think dress with
it don't go spits it and it's so many of
the former so much of the former Soviet
Union
they've taken statues like these down
but in chemical I don't know why it's
still here there's a couple of so two of
them Lenin no graffiti freshly painted
the geography is very interesting here
is so far so far from everything what
was it six seven hours by taxi from the
capital Bishkek and that's the quickest
way in a bus would take an eternity
China is just roughly eighty miles away
and then you have Tajikistan and below
Tajikistan is Afghanistan and below
Afghanistan or to the side of
Afghanistan is Pakistan but if you go to
the north here it's Kazakhstan through
the plains to Russia chemical was a
Russian military outpost founded in 1869
so it has some of that rusev I'd feel to
it you have these beautiful gingerbread
type homes with these ornate window
sills and these beautiful detail in
flying
look at that it's Lenin Street they
didn't change it a lot of these
buildings are very colorful and on the
opposite side it has well a lot of stuff
that's just barely hanging on a lot of
decay a lot of things falling apart
you can see a lot of charm here and you
can see a lot of a lot of grit I've only
been here two and a half days but
there's always the sound of the rustling
leaves there's a a nice breeze coming
through this place very very fresh
mountain air yeah it's giving it
[Music]
my name is Elam ja LM sure you're from
category yes
Kargil is the best place in the world
for me yeah if you like mountains fresh
air beautiful lake yes you were telling
me about Europe because you travel to
Europe a lot yes and what do you think
you know I see
Europe is a beautiful watch people for
me strange I think these people not
smiling the life like zombies the life
is like a zombie what do you mean what
do you mean by that you're just working
most farming said
and then died yes but when I ask ask the
people in Europe answer for my question
smile
we were just near market yes buzzer yes
good guy I'm a different world for both
you and then we're in the osore it's
like you're in Hong Kong so it's very
mixed because of the geography and the
history there's this crazy smash of
cultures and so you see a beautiful
russian orthodox church and not far away
there's uh there's a mosque a Chinese
mosque and a lot of Chinese left I
believe in the 19th century left China
to come here to practice their religion
and this is a completely nailless mosque
and with the the russian orthodox church
when the soviets came they outlawed
religions so they turn the church and
all sorts of things at one time someone
told me it was a market then I read it
was a nightclub then I met red it was a
place to store coal like a Depot for
coal a ladies gymnasium and an
institution for higher education all
within this church and when the Soviet
Union fell it went back to being an
Orthodox Church that is just be really
another ultram devavrata cut again water
on this room Wow filming it's an
interesting place just to as a foreigner
just to walk around and then you see the
from the Soviet times like these
government buildings which depends on
your your take on beauty if they're
beautiful or not but I some of them are
really cool really like them big parks
one of the parks completely decrepit
broke down another one nice so you feel
the decay and then there's a stadium and
the stadium is alive and a bunch of
people working out and kids playing song
all with this like stunning backdrop of
the mountains
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've never seen a market like this I
love just canvassing bazaars and markets
and random places on the planet they all
have something in common and they all
have something different this one for
example I've never seen one where it's
just completely crates or shipping
containers so in these markets you can
pretty much get everything you need for
living and they're usually broken off in
this section so food clothes there's a
magazine which is a store some meat or
clothes summer time rafting lots of
toilet paper it's interesting the
marijuana leaves I've seen everywhere
it's illegal but I've heard heard they
grow a lot up in these in these parts
and I heard it's a very good weed
okay spasiba
spasiba let's see that even this guy
azad he was fixing his car and i just
asked him where the mosque was so this
is how it works in Quetta call i was
walking down the street and I asked azad
where the mosque was he said let me show
you until we run a long walk to find the
moss and that's how it works here very
nice people very hospitable man yeah
that's what's that's what's really
special about this part of the world
it's like not everyone's fighting time I
mean there's a pro and a con to that but
the pro is like people have time to be
spontaneous like this I envy a little
bit the fact that people have this spare
time you feel it up here and maybe
there's a I'm sure there's a stuckness
I'm sure a lot of the people young
people feel stuck here I would
definitely feel stuck here and then some
of the young people told me they loved
it this is where they want to be I went
on a search for some local food just got
a hot tip from a local saying that this
market has the best
ashlynn Fuu I believe it's called which
is a local dish classic dish Rossiter
LaVon says arsalan foo ultram Posner
Luce will Caracalla Martha was not for
Johnston that Austria
spasiba us in you
thank you son got a call from Kirikou
Haruto good yeah dr. Stan cuz then Kazan
interests me gotta class Salam alaikum
Salam alaikum he had San Francisco or
Qin delica a sh Lin feels like a noodle
dish with a very nice spicy broth and
then egg and some other things I didn't
know what they were in there it was a
real gem that was very good and then
they have a lot of Fred there's just a
lot of freshness like fresh strawberries
fresh raspberries and so it's like
picked in granny's garden type fresh
deity this place catechol I think it
would take years in this region to
really understand the dynamics and inner
workings of the place it's got a depth
it's got a it's got a power it's got a
feeling to it I'm only like surface
level I know that it's really hard to
you know get into the linguistic side of
things get into the cultural side of
things but just as a tourist you know
tourist perspective it's it's a really
cool place you know if you're looking
for the you know the perfect vacation as
in no dust and everything's just looks
great then chemical is not the place but
it's definitely the place for those that
are curious interested in a very raw
fenton corner of the world
it's just strikingly beautiful it's it's
one of the most beautiful places in
[Music]
class druggy your brother's cool cause
cousins